quand on n'est pas content quelque chose
il saignait refasse une chimère
facilement ouais c'est le seul et plein
de défauts oui seul défaut
ouais tu vois pas autre chose qu'est ce
qui fait le plus mal dans la vie mon
père oui rien bon c'est bien des trucs
il fait mal mais non je vois pas si j'ai
vécu avec mon père du joueur qui joue
que de bonheur groupe a du mal il
s'énerve facilement mais c'est tout oui
il est bien des choses qui n'arrivent
pas à faire comme peut-être pris de
colin kahl cochon wade n'est pas je vois
mal qu'est ce qu'il y avait mauvais
bricoleur bah oui je pense
qu'est-ce qui l'a jamais compris votre
père à votre avis jamais compris quelque
chose qui va jamais compris messieurs et
vous poser des questions mais vraiment
on n'y a pas là qu'elle n'y a pas de
réponse
très bien bien des choses qu'il n'a
jamais compris quand même dans la vie
non moi je prends une chose c'est
qu'elle est très bien compris que ma
part m'a accueilli à votre avis qu'est
ce que mitterrand avait de plus que
votre peur rien c'est comme ça
extraordinaire monsieur mitterrand bien
ce bar le respect parce que monsieur
mitterrand décédé mais c'est que c'est
quelqu'un m'ait vraiment exemplaire mais
mon père aussi quelques importants
poillion il vous est déjà monté votre
peur dans la vie il faut manquer si ça
fait mal à personne
ah bah oui c'est mon mari mais dix
étaient déjà faits peut-être je n'ai pas
fait mais je vais le faire après mais sa
part que dit oui mais voilà si qu'on la
pensait qu'on était mal à personne
thierry que qu'est ce qui n'a jamais su
vous dire votre peur il m'a tout dire
que des bonheurs que des messiriya vous
pouvez pas vous pouvez pas me demander
quoi que j'ai je peux pas vous donner
quoi se soit tiré
pas un morceau c'est malheureux un sacré
personnage mois
toute petite déjà elle était infernal
mais je sais c'est bon c'est m'épouser
j'étais petit quand j'étais petit au
vietnam elle mangeait que le blanc de
poulet tout à fait ça alan la ccac bas
étant des séjours on peut pas manger
blond poulets bérol ma prof les larmes
à l'extérieur il ya bien des choses où
il s'est planté quand même jacques
chirac y à bien il a bien fait des
erreurs quand même d'autres termes on
vous parlait de ça sa vie
professionnelle
non non il y en a beaucoup écouté
bon alors ça regarde qu'à lui à vous
pensez vous avez compris tromper je n'ai
pas j'ai rien vu c'est donc évidemment
interprété et cirés or je dirais jamais
son nom mais mon père est maintenant
bien sûr mais ça regarde conduit qui a
su une point final
voilà une affaire mais non mais manger
ni sa fille est chez nous surtout mais
faut quand même de respect et mon père
parce que si par exemple votre sommeil
les vols il est d'enfer où vous voulez
pas considéré comme un bottin
malgré tout c'est un bonheur c'est bon